after completing four years of study in
the subject students are awarded a
professional undergraduate engineering
degree program known as the bachelor of
technology in b-tech we have several
departments like civil engineering
computer science mechanical engineering
and many more
did you know india has the largest
engineering students engineering
education institutes and infrastructure
globally as of 2021 india annually
produced five black engineering
graduates therefore if you are a
pre-tech student you should be aware of
all your options for employment after
completing your b-tech here we are
presenting a new video by simply learn
that will help you to know the career
options after btec but before we begin
the session subscribe to our channel and
hit the bell icon to get more
interesting updates majorly you have
three sectors where you can build your
career after p-tech that is the private
sector government sector and psu
first comes the private sector the
various privately held i.t and non-id
companies that the government does not
govern are considered to be the private
sector there are three categories in
this technical non-technical and core
technical is the department and id
companies that work on the current
technologies and problems like big data
blockchain artificial intelligence and
many more two types of organizations
that come under the technical sector are
product based and service based if you
are good at coding data structures and
algorithms you can opt to build your
career with the product based companies
like microsoft google goldman sachs etc
if you are a person who is good at
aptitude and have some basic knowledge
of data structures then you can go for
service-based companies like tcs web pro
enforcers etc let's know the difference
between building a carrier and product
and service based companies the major
difference is in pay
in product based companies candidates
are selected based on the demand and
requirements and their pay ranges
between a minimum of 7 to 8 lakhs per
annum to a maximum of 40 to 50 lakhs per
annum
service based companies are majorly mass
recruiters and they are pay ranges
between a minimum of 2 to 3 lakhs per
annum to a maximum of 12 lakhs per annum
the second category is non-technical
companies which are not related to
technology and primarily focus on
business for example companies like kpmp
white ice etc hire consulting or
management profiles where your major
responsibility is interacting with the
client this type of profile primarily
requires good communication skills which
help you interact with people and build
a positive personality if you are a
person who is good at communication
skills and presentation skills you can
go for the non-technical companies
the last category is core companies
these companies are highly specialized
in their core industries and are highly
rated for their skills and experience
these companies offer jobs in the core
areas of engineering such as mechanical
civil electrical etc for example the
tata industry's most successful and
biggest business unit in india hires
most mechanical engineering students and
other companies such as avcon's
infrastructure limited and punch lloyd
hire several brand students which
majorly focuses on construction
the second sector you can build your
career in is the government sector the
government sector is also called the
public sector which includes the public
goods and governmental services such as
the military law enforcement and many
more some students want to work in the
government sector after their btec or be
for which they will prepare from the
second or third year of engineering if
you are interested in doing online jobs
after your graduation you can take up
the following government exams
upsc union public service commission is
the most popular and known by everyone
and as a recruiting agency for top-level
central government jobs such as ias ips
etc the next is ssc cgl staff selection
commission combined graduate level
this exam will help you become an
inspector sub-inspector etc the next are
some of the public sector banks ibps sbi
if you are interested in working in a
bank you can take up some ibps and other
bank exams like sbi etc if you are
interested in developing or innovating
and in research you can become a
scientist and esro or drdo
the last sector is psus psus is the
public sector undertakings these are the
companies where the 51 share is of the
government and 49 share is of private
companies here you will get the benefits
of both government and private companies
in india you have so many psus in
different categories like transportation
banking hospital insurance etc some of
the psus are bharat petroleum indian oil
corporation esro bsnl bhel sale ntpc
dmrs etc you can visit their website to
see the requirements and eligibility and
apply for your interested one if you are
interested in higher studies you can
offer masters in ms m-tech and me for ms
you can prepare for exams like gre and
t-o-e-f-l or toffel
if you are interested in mtech you can
prepare for exams like gate jntu cet if
you want to go for me you can prepare
for exams like gate t-a-n-c-e-t
try applying for a teaching position for
btec be or bca students if you don't
have strong coding skills but are a
master in theoretical concepts
so till now you got to know the
different career options after
completing your btec i hope you guys
like this video do share this with your
friends and let me know your career
option after btec in the comment box for
more updates visit our simply learn
youtube channel thanks for watching stay
safe and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here